well the Israeli government unveiled a
huge trove of intelligence on Iran on
Monday night the Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu made the case that Iran lied
when it negotiated a 2015 nuclear deal
sounds right the revelations appear to
increase the chances that the Trump
administration will repudiate the Iran
deal which the president of course ran
against that could put the u.s. though
on the path to yet another military
venture in that region is that in our
strategic interest
Colonel Doug McClure is a retired Army
colonel he's author of the book margin
of victory which is excellent and he
joins us tonight colonel thanks for
coming on thank you let's start the
simple question first and and I'm
assuming that all of this Intel is real
and I certainly never assume good faith
in the part of Iran obviously is it in
our strategic interest to have a
conflict with the wrong well I think the
answer is pretty clearly no there's no
benefit to the United States from going
to war with Iran none well that's not
the impression you get from listening to
for example nikki Haley many Republicans
in the Congress so a lot of Democrats
seem to believe that it's essential of
the United States goes to war well I
think we have a case here of the
proverbial tail wagging the dog
we have two smaller allies one is Tel
Aviv the other is Riyadh both of them
clearly would like to see Iran end up as
a smoking ruin at some point and
whatever they can do to persuade us to
abandon this joint comprehensive plan of
action they will do in the hopes that
that then will clear away the obstacle
to direct military confrontation hmm but
again and by the way let me just say I
understand why both them would want that
I don't grudge them that I would want
that too if I were them yes but what
effect would that have in the United
States that's my main interest is in
America well first of all if you go to
war you're in territory that is very
hard to predict in other words Iran is
not isolated Iran is not alone and we
don't have China for instance telling
the leader of North Korea shut up and do
business with the United States which is
effectively what happened with GE and
that by the way is a brilliant
achievement by the president I hope he
focuses on that not this particular
issue right now
but we don't have anything like that and
the Iranians and the Russians have drawn
very close closely together the Chinese
are in the in the background but they're
doing a land office business with Iran
and oil and gas the Europeans look at us
and are dismayed because from their
vantage point it's it's not Iran it's
the Sunni Islamist Arabs and Turks
stupid that's where you should be
focused and I wouldn't for us as well I
don't remember a lot of xi8 inspired
terror attacks on our soil and I keep
hearing that Iran which I'm not in any
way defending and I would used to live
there but I keep hearing they're the
greatest threat to Americans but it
seems like all the terror attacks in
this country are Sunni absolutely no
there's no question about that and again
look if you're if you're interested in
securing your country against that kind
of thing you defend your borders you get
control of immigration we forget that
9/11 crew came here legally became
illegal was never tracked and was able
to do what they did is they agents of
Iran no of course not they were agents
of well they were Sunni Sunni Arab
Islamists largely from Saudi Arabia
North Africa right so why wouldn't we
see that as the threat because
consistently over time it has been why
is everyone saying exactly the opposite
of what's so clearly true I think it's
pretty clear that our two allies in
tel-aviv and Saudi Arabia are absolutely
determined to halt what they consider to
be the onward march of Iranian influence
right and that that influence is
confined right now largely not
exclusively but largely to Syria and
Iraq we forget of course that we
installed Iran in power in Iraq we
created the conditions conducive to that
that was not something wrong did and
when it comes to Syria the Iranians have
worked closely with the Russians and
Assad to defeat the Sunni Islamist
opposition to them and they've been
successful that war is effectively over
so the bottom line is they want us to
effectively reverse the strategic
outcomes of the last what 15 16 years
that's not possible frankly without a
major war and I don't think that
President Trump is interested remotely
under any circumstances in going to war
but the GC or this joint comprehensive
plan of action is
the last obstacle on the road to war
because that proves that we can achieve
our strategic games without going to war
I just hope that we keep American
interest foremost in line because that's
the point of the US government
of course colonel thanks thanks for
coming on sure shoot that